Please help me welcome to the stage Tara Mohr.
Yeah.
Thank you for having me.
Everybody can hear me.
Okay,
great.
Oh,
I'm so happy to be here.
Uh,
this is the neck of the woods where I grew up actually.
So nice to be back down on the peninsula and I'm really thrilled to be talking
with all of you about women playing big,
how we end up playing small and how we can play bigger.
And I want to begin by sharing with you why I started doing this work and how I
came to be thinking about these topics.
About 10 years ago,
I was starting to make a big transition in my own career.
I had identified that I didn't really love the work I was doing and I wanted to
be doing work that dealt with people's inner lives and helping them create the
lives and careers they really want it.
And I didn't know exactly what that would look like,
but I thought coaching would have something to do with it.
And so I had gotten trained as a coach and while I was still working full time
in another job during the evenings and the weekends,
I was squeezing in this exploration of this new area and starting to coach
mostly friends of friends and colleagues of colleagues who had heard.
I was exploring coaching and starting a little bit about starting a little
coaching practice.
And most of the women that came to that practice,
I had the exact same response to,
I would sit across from these women in a coaching session and get to hear about
their dreams,
what they wanted for their careers,
what they saw that was happening in their company or their organization that
they had a critique of or a better vision for what they thought their industry
was missing.
I got to hear all of these amazing reflections of their insights and their
brilliance.
And I just became so inspired by every single one of them,
by the ideas they had,
by their thoughtfulness,
by how ethical,
uh,
and conscientious they were in their approach to their work.
And so I just wanted to see them leading and having more influence.
And power in our world and yet over and over and over again,
I heard the same things from them.
I'm not ready yet to take that next step.
I probably need more training first.
I need a few more years experience.
Don't I need another degree?
If that was a good idea,
someone would have thought of it already.
Let me think about that more and do more research on it before I do anything
about it.
And I started to feel really pained by this because as we all know,
right?
We look in the news headlines or we see the decisions that are being made by
people in leadership and we know that seems like our world deserves better.
And here I was sitting across from these women,
I thought this is the better that we deserve.
And yet it's somehow not that brilliant isn't really making it to the seats of
power and the places of influence where it deserves to be.
And so that phenomenon,
that gap between potential and how people saw themselves,
I needed a shorthand way to label and playing small.
It seemed like a good term for it.
And about the same time I had started blogging about personal growth topics and
professional development topics and a few years into blogging my readership had
grown and I got very curious to learn more about who is reading and why and so I
sent out a survey to my readers and in the survey one of the questions was,
what's the biggest challenge in your life?
Right?
Probably many of you know from your work.
That's a great market research question.
You want to know what are people feeling pained by and challenged by and knowing
that most of my readers were women.
I had this list of options on the multiple choice survey of things I thought
might be the biggest challenge in their life.
So of course I put work family balance on there because that's what everybody
talks about is huge challenge and women's lives.
I put a health issues up there and financial issues,
relationship challenges,
I'm not sure what I want.
Right?
A whole host of things from different domains of life.
And then I looked at that list and I thought it was actually nothing on that
list that reflects what I'm hearing from women in my coaching practice.
And so kind of on a whim I added,
I'm playing small as a possible challenge that people could choose.
And when the responses came back that was what the most women said was the
biggest challenge in their life.
I'm playing small and that was so striking to me that we,
so many of us are walking around with some sense that we're playing small and we
feel challenged by it.
Meaning we must somehow be stuck there.
We don't know how to fix that or change it.
And so that became the focus of my work,
trying to understand why are we playing small and then most importantly,
what really makes a difference,
what makes a difference.
So we stopped thing,
I'm not ready yet.
We stopped saying I need more qualifications.
We start sharing more of ourselves,
more bravely.
And I found through my coaching practice that there really were some tools and
some new pieces of knowledge and some every day moment to moment practices we
could do that produced really big change for people quite consistently,
whether they were in a junior or senior level of their career,
whether they were working in business or the social sector,
whether they were entrepreneurs or inside a large organization.
The kind of fundamentals have changed that needed to happen where the same and
those fundamentals became the basis for the work that I now do for leadership
trainings for the buck.
And we're going to talk about some of the key pieces of that today.
Before we jump into that,
there's one important thing I want to address because we are going to be talking
today about the inner barriers for women around our playing bigger.
And it can be easy for that to be misconstrued as then that disparity that we
see in leadership,
the challenges that women face are inside us all our own fault,
right?
And I certainly don't want to convey that in any way.
So first I want to give voice to,
of course there are huge external barriers,
many of which I'm sure through the women at Google work you're learning about
here,
all kinds of bias and implicit and explicit discrimination,
the pay gap,
so on and so on.
Right?
Um,
and there are these inner issues and the inner barriers that we face,
the kind of playing small I'm talking about,
I don't see as disconnected from those external barriers that at all.
So we didn't just make this up because we thought it would be great to play
small and hold ourselves back,
but rather that if you think about what it means to be a woman right in our time
right now,
we are in this amazing transitional moment in history.
We're coming out of thousands of years of a legacy where women were pretty much
marginalized entirely from professional life,
political life,
public life,
and the legacy of that,
the residue of that is still so alive in our culture in many ways in our media.
It's so alive in the messages we get at school and often at home as well.
And that has certain effects on how we see ourselves and how we behave.
And so when we talk about the inner barriers,
we're really talking about the inner imprint of that legacy and have that
culture.
Okay.
So with that,
let's jump in.
We'll talk about three areas today where I commonly see so many women holding
themselves back and where we can make really transformative change.
And the first one is our inner critics.
So anyone have one of these?
Yes.
Two hands.
Two hands go up.
Yeah.
Anyone feel like you don't have an inner critic that you're burdened by or
affected by as you move through your life or your work?
Okay.
Yeah,
so most of us are aware that we do have this voice in our head that says not
very nice things to us about ourselves,
that voices a lot of self doubt.
And as much as we're aware of it,
we also probably don't even notice.
For most of us,
we don't even notice about 90% of what it's saying because it's become so
habitual.
It's the water that we swim in,
right?
So that thought,
oh,
I'm just not good at that whole set of things.
Oh,
there's no way I could be the person to do that.
Right?
Things that maybe we just feel like that's true about us or that's our way of
thinking is often the inner critic.
So the first piece of work we need to do is start to recognize,
when am I hearing my inner critic and start to notice it as a voice in our
heads,
not just how my,
my thinking sounds,
not just that's who I am,
but start to notice it as one voice so that over time we can get connected to
some of the other voices inside of us.
So how do we recognize it?
We listen for when do you hear a voice talking to you in a way that you would
not intend to talk to someone you love?
When do you hear the voice of I'm not ready yet.
That's usually your inner critic for women.
Interestingly,
there is really not good research that says we have more self doubt than men.
That's a common misunderstanding.
Uh,
but there is data that suggest women do feel more self doubt than men around
those things that are traditionally associated with masculinity in our culture.
So that's quantitative work,
financial work and decisions,
negotiation and leadership.
There we see that women tend to have more self doubt about themselves in those
areas of skill and work.
On the other side of the coin,
there's some data that suggests that men feel more self doubt around emotional
and relational skills like listening,
reading nonverbal cues and communication.
So our self doubt of course is showing up and what's been conditioned in our
culture to have us think it's associated with us or people like us.
So listen,
particularly when do you notice that voice of I'm just not good at those kinds
of things.
That's your inner critic.
You might notice your inner critic is often also for women,
the voice of body perfectionism or self consciousness around our bodies.
Uh,
it tends to be a very repetitive,
broken record kind of voice.
Uh,
and it may take some cues from outer critics in your life,
right?
So you might notice,
oh,
that inner critic voice is saying a lot of things that when I really think about
it,
that sounds an internalized voice of that really tough first boss I had.
Or that professor who delivered that really,
really harsh feedback or that person in my childhood who was very critical of
me.
But it,
that's not true for everyone.
You don't have to find an external source for your critic.
You might just notice some echoes there.
So starting to notice that voice.
A question I get a lot around,
uh,
noticing the inner critic is what's the difference between the inner critic and
realistic thinking,
right?
What's there's good critical thinking that might realistically assess something
and come back with you now that's not that good.
You're not ready yet.
I'm not good at that,
right?
So how do we know when we're hearing that more irrational inner critic versus
realistic thinking
and the way you can tell the difference there is really the tone of the thoughts
in your head.
It's not even a distinction of what those two voices say.
They might have the same concerns.
I'm not sure you're ready for that stretch assignment yet,
but the way they talk to you about that,
those those concerns will be very different.
So the inner critic will sound more anxious,
more chattery,
more repetitive.
I'm not sure if I'm ready.
I really don't think I could do that.
What if this worst case scenario happens more fearful about future consequences?
And you'll notice that if it's your inner critic,
it's not trying to move towards any solution or resolution of the problem.
Realistic thinking might say,
you know,
I am not sure if I'm ready.
If I have what I need to take that stretch assignment.
How can I find that out?
Who could I talk to?
How can I evaluate it?
How can I test it?
Is there a low risk way to do it?
Let's think through what would be the worst thing that could happen so you can
hear the tone.
Realistic thinking is curious.
It's generative and it's on your side.
It moves forward,
down and half of reasoning.
Whereas your inner critic is going to loop and loop and loop.
So why do we have this inner critic?
What is it?
No mistake that I think a lot of us make and I used to share this misconception,
is that if we're not confident,
if we feel a lot of self doubt,
one that's a personal problem,
something missing from us as individuals and to that somehow if we look back
into our history,
we can find the reason for it.
Was it that I never learned to develop enough confidence doing competitive
things as a kid?
Was that these critical people in my life?
What is it that my parents were so supportive of me that now,
right?
The world feels really dangerous and scary and contrast and and everything feels
so critical.
We look to our biography for some sort of reason for that self doubt and after
talking to so many women about their inner critics and really digging into the
mechanics of self doubt,
I can say that that's not the place to find the answer.
There's nothing in your life experience that is responsible for self doubt,
that in fact we're all hardwired.
We're all hardwired to have that inner critic voice.
And the reason is this,
that we all have a very strong safety instinct,
right?
And the safety instinct is the part of us that wants to keep us safe from harm
at any cost.
It's a very old,
ancient reptilian part of that comes from the reptilian part of our brain that's
always on the lookout for danger and risk,
right?
And is trying to make sure we survive.
That was very useful when human beings were faced with a lot of life
threatening,
dangerous all the time.
That instinct to look for danger and go into fight or flight when we perceive
any possible danger is still alive in all of us.
And in our modern time.
It doesn't just fire when there's a physical threat,
it fires when there's an emotional threat.
So when we feel an emotional threat,
like I might really embarrass myself saying that,
that idea,
I might really,
uh,
bring some conflict or criticism.
If I point out the elephant in the room that I see that nobody's talking about
here,
I might fail.
I might be criticized.
Those are all things we perceive as emotional threats.
And the safety instinct is saying,
no,
we got to avoid all of those.
Let's stay in the comfort zone.
But if every time you wanted to take a stretch,
a step in your life or make a change or do something that risked emotional harm,
if every time your safety instinct just said,
hi,
I'm your safety instinct,
I don't like that.
I think we should stay exactly what the status quo.
I think we should stay really safe over here.
Let's not try it.
Let's not speak up.
You would say,
no,
I want to,
I,
I have a longing in me to try that thing.
I want to make this change.
And you would pretty quickly overrule your safety instinct.
So our safety instincts have developed a more sophisticated,
more effective strategy at getting us to stay in the comfort zone.
Instead of saying,
hi,
I'm your safety instinct,
please don't do that.
The safety instinct says you have no idea what you're talking about.
Who Do you think you are?
You're not ready to say that yet.
Let's go research it for a few months first and then come back and say it.
And that is an intimidating enough narrative to get most of us to stay in that
comfort zone.
So the inner critic is a strategy that your safety instinct is using to make
sure you don't do things that raise that risk of emotional vulnerability or
possible emotional discomfort.
And the problem is that just like an accompany,
you end up a lot of problems when you have two departments that don't coordinate
it all.
The risk aversion department in us never talks to the fulfillment department or
the reward department.
It doesn't care.
It really doesn't care if you ever have a fulfill day in your life.
It has one mission stay in the comfort zone.
So if we listen to it,
that's what happens.
We stay in the comfort zone,
but we miss out on a lot.
And that's what happens when we listen to our inner critics.
So if we're hardwired for self doubt,
what do we do?
What do we do about that?
Safety instinct isn't going anywhere.
Our desire to do things that have us risking failure and criticism also isn't
going anywhere,
so the thing we don't try and do is become confident and this is where I am
against all this advice that women should just become more confident,
that we've got to encourage our girls to be confident that confidence is the
answer because I know that the women who are leading and risking and speaking on
and excelling don't feel confident as they're doing it.
A couple of my favorite examples of this one comes from Twyla Tharp,
who is many people I've heard of,
Twyla Tharp.
She's one of the most famous choreographers of our time.
She is one about 10 Tony Awards.
She has tons of honorary degrees.
Her work is celebrated all over the world and she says,
every time I start a new dance,
when I go into the studio,
I am completely sure that this is the one where the audience is going to walk
out on opening night laughing because they're going to see my talent has run
out.
Another one of my favorite examples comes from Cherry Murray,
who is the dean of engineering at Harvard,
and she says,
every single day I feel unqualified for my job.
So what's fascinating about that,
right,
is that Twyla Tharp is doing the dance anyway,
and Terry Murray took that job and continues to show up at that job anyway.
And that's the name of the game.
It's how do I hear the voice of self doubt?
It's going to be very loud if you are truly playing to your potential,
it's going to be very loud if you're sharing your voice and your gifts in the
world because the safety doesn't like the respite comes with that.
So how do we let it be there and hear it,
but not take direction from it in just that way that Cherry Murray and Twyla
Tharp are talking about?
So to do that,
we need to one,
know that it's that voice when it's talking,
right?
Twyla Tharp actually says,
and then I think,
oh,
there's that voice again.
It's been there with me for every dance.
I've started to choreograph and I know if I listened to it,
I would stop choreographing entirely,
right?
So hearing the voice of self doubt,
recognizing it for what it is you can even ask yourself in the moment,
what does my safety instinct not like about this situation?
When you hear self doubt,
so if you here,
I'm really just always been horrible at that and I'm going to totally screw this
up.
What does my safety instinct not like about this situation?
And you'll see it immediately,
oh it doesn't like that.
I'm going to get feedback on this.
That might hurt.
It doesn't like that.
If I apply for this,
I may get it or not,
right?
And then you can start to see why the inner critic is speaking up.
Um,
it can also be fun.
Just a few more playful strategies you can use.
You can create a character for your inner critic.
So think about if you are going to give it a personality,
what kind of personality,
what kind of character personifies it for you.
And then when you hear that voice,
you can notice it come as coming from that character.
Whether you imagine that visually or it's a particular voice and that can just
add some lightness and you can see the humor in what it's saying and also it can
help you remember,
that's not the core of me.
The core of me is the part that has that desire to fulfill my potential.
Um,
you can also even sometimes imagine it leaving the space that you're in.
So if you are writing an important email and you notice you're feeling like
you're being very perfectionistic and the editing of it and feeling like it's
not going to come across right,
and you're hearing a lot of self doubt about what you're saying,
to actually picture that inner critic voice,
leaving the room or picture of the character leaving the room and then come back
to your screen.
Okay,
now it's just me.
Let's go.
And it sounds hard to believe,
but that actually can make a really powerful difference for people and how,
how present that voices for them.
So noticing the inner critic voice,
learning to live with it,
not waiting on confidence.
Please do not wait on confidence for anything that you're wanting to do.
But rather the answer is it's not becoming confident.
It's having a new kind of relationship with self doubt.
Okay.
So let's move on to a second topic,
which is unhooking from praise and criticism and hooking from praise and
criticism.
And this is an area that that really surprised me in my work with women to see
how many of the issues that people were coming to coaching with looked like.
One thing on the surface,
but really something else that had to do with their relationship to praise and
criticism.
So one of,
uh,
my clients came with,
I've been working in my field for 25 years.
I have done really well in it,
but I see this huge problem with the conventional way things are approached in
my field.
She worked in a domestic violence prevention and and services.
I see this huge problem and I want to start my own program with a different
approach and my job is so demanding.
I'm so overtaxed I can never get to this thing.
I want a coach to help me carve out the time and hold me accountable so I can
make some movement on this thing.
Okay,
great.
While I didn't know yet what I know now,
it's just time is never the real issue.
It's maybe the real issue 0.5% of the time.
But when we delved a little deeper,
what was clear for her was she had always been a star within her field.
She had always gotten a lot of uh,
positive feedback and excelled in the conventional way and she knew that this
new approach that she wanted to bring forward was going to be controversial.
And as someone who had always been a good student in school and done well at
work that moved to how am I going to launch something that I know will be
controversial,
can I live with the criticism and feedback and the polarized reactions that are
going to come my way was really what was keeping her stuck.
So that's one example.
Another was a woman who works in management consulting who said,
you know,
I love my job,
I love the analysis.
I really liked the work with clients,
but I have been promoted to this new level and now where I am,
there's a lot of harsh feedback coming my way.
Some of it is at this level,
the way my colleagues and I,
the culture of how we talk to each other.
There's just a lot of criticism.
Some of it is that now when the client doesn't like something,
I'm the one that's hearing everything about it.
And I am finding myself so on such an emotional rollercoaster with that.
And so I'm uncomfortable with it that it's keeping me from liking my job.
So I'm coming to coaching to figure out should I change careers or wait,
that doesn't seem right because I love the actual heart of the work.
And so with her,
again,
we had to look at what,
what's this relationship to criticism and negative feedback and how does that
block us?
Uh,
I have really found that for every person,
um,
and particularly for women,
there is a point where we get stopped in our growth because of our relationship
to praise and criticism.
And that could be where avoidant of criticism we're seeking of praise.
For some of us,
it's that we're avoidant of a lot of praise.
Paradoxically,
if you grew up in a culture where you're not,
you're supposed to blend in and don't brag and don't do things,
don't try and be in the spotlight,
you will unconsciously or consciously avoid the things that will bring a lot of
praise.
So that's another way we can get hooked.
And so part of this journey to playing bigger is unhooking from praise and
criticism.
This does affect women in particular in a few ways.
Certainly all of us human beings were affected by praise and criticism.
But there's some interesting dimensions of how it affects women in particular.
One is that we know women get more harsh criticism then men in the workforce and
we get more personal criticism.
Um,
so some of you may have seen the study that was done by Kieran Snyder.
She's a linguist and a,
uh,
a tech entrepreneur.
And she did a study looking at a performance reviews from about 30 tech
companies and analyzing them using a variety of linguistic tools.
And she found that not only did women get a lot more negative feedback than men
in their performance reviews,
but 73% of the negative feedback that women got was criticism of their
personality.
And 2% of the negative feedback that men got was criticism of a personality
trait.
So this sense of the feedback we get is more personal and therefore more
wounding for us,
of course,
and more became something that we are more alert on avoiding.
There's a real gender gap there,
right in the kind of feedback we get.
So of course,
as a result of that,
we're going to feel more hooked,
more caught up in what's going on with the negative feedback we get.
Another interesting factor that has a gender dimension,
uh,
is what I call the noisy room.
And I call it the noisy room because I always felt when I was working inside a
large organization,
if I was in a meeting with 15 people around a conference table,
that room felt incredibly noisy to me with the cues and the dynamics of
everything that was going on amongst that group.
So when people were talking,
I would be noticing,
you know,
that person really seems to be resisting everything that person's saying and
that person's in a really grumpy mood today and that person's always just trying
to win over these three people.
All those dynamics,
right?
Very,
very full of information.
And I found that for me that often sometimes got in the way of my ability to
really push forward in the midst of complex dynamics,
um,
and kind of see the main,
see the main event or let those dynamics just be and let the project go forward
without feeling like they needed to be resolved.
So I had noticed that in myself and notice that I didn't see,
uh,
some of my male colleagues grappling with all of,
they weren't even aware of the things I was talking about.
You know,
if I had just to bring them up to be resolved,
the often they weren't even aware and they certainly didn't think they needed to
be resolved.
And so then I was really intrigued when I read that there's research that
supports exactly what that experience was on,
uh,
one that there is a gender difference in the amount of information that women
and men pick up in nonverbal cues.
There's very few gender differences that actually are consistently borne out by
the research.
One of them that there's a pretty solid body of studies around is that women
pick up a lot more information from facial expressions,
from body language.
And so if you think about what that means,
it means we're processing a lot more and that includes people's reactions to us,
right?
We're processing a lot more of people,
subtle reactions to us than our male counterparts are.
And that's something that can be distracting for us.
Study.
This particular study done at Harvard also found that contrary to all that
research on the emotional,
uh,
the benefits of high emotional intelligence,
there's also some downsides of high emotional intelligence around morale and
productivity,
which I think really speaks to what I'm talking about,
right?
If you very high emotional intelligence,
you're picking up all those cues.
It can interfere with a certain kind of productivity.
You may feel kind of down about the dynamics you're observing that other people
aren't even noticing.
So that's another way we can get hooked on people's reactions to us.
We just get more information about that.
As women,
we're oblivious to less and that can be helpful,
but we have to be really discerning about when it's helpful and when it's not.
Uh,
and then lastly,
another factor that informs our relationship to feedback is,
is our history again.
And if you think about women's history,
right?
For most of our history,
women could not survive through financial power,
political power,
physical strength.
We didn't have those things,
right?
We weren't going to be able to survive or ensure the survival of our dearest
ones through physical night,
through political rights,
through legal protection,
through financial ownership of property.
We didn't have any of those things.
And our primary survival strategy,
or you could also say our primary service strategy for thriving was social
influence and likability,
right?
Working through relationships to do what would be approved of or tolerable or
met with uh,
a positive reaction.
And the reason that's so important is because for a lot of us,
there's a kind of legacy of that that still lives where conflict or harsh
criticism really does feel life threatening really can feel life threatening if
we really tune in to our inner experience of it.
And that's why.
So how do we unhook from praise and criticism?
There are a bunch of strategies in the book.
There's one I want to focus on today,
which is changing your story about feedback.
And the new story that I want to offer you today is a little bit,
it sounds a little bit radical to some people at first.
So hang in there with me and it's this,
that feedback never tells you anything about yourself.
It can only tell you about the person giving the feedback.
So I'm guessing this is a pretty feedback oriented culture.
Yes,
we have to take feedback very seriously.
It's going to help us grow.
It's key to our development.
Integral something great leaders are always looking for a lot of feedback.
So to say,
feedback can never tell any,
tell you anything about you.
It can only tell you about the people you're getting feed back from.
Kinda thought seems like it flies in the face of that.
So let's talk about that for a minute.
So let's say,
uh,
your manager says you are a really great,
you're really great with details and project management.
Um,
but you know,
I,
there's something missing in the sort of team interaction and the ability to
motivate people and make them feel comfortable kind of on the soft skills sky.
There's something missing.
So that's the feedback.
So what does that tell us about you?
Does that tell us you're a good project manager?
Does that tell us there's something missing in the soft skill side?
Does it tell us any facts about that?
Really when you think about it,
the only fact we're actually getting there is the fact of that is the feedback
my manager gave me.
That sounds like that's the feedback.
That is the uh,
his or her perception,
his or her experience of my work.
That's the fact.
That's his or her experience of my work.
What if your whole team says,
well,
you're a really great project manager,
great with the details,
but we all feel kind of like we can't connect or you didn't know were not really
motivated by you.
Does that give us any facts about you?
Okay.
Does that give us some facts about that group of people?
Perhaps some facts about what's coming across to them.
Okay.
Tells us about their experience of you.
So,
okay,
the next step there is not to dismiss the feedback.
This is not,
oh,
that's all about them.
So I'm going to ignore it.
It's,
oh,
that's giving me information about these individuals and if these are people
that I want to work with effectively,
if these are important stakeholders to what I'm doing,
I'm going to really listen to that feedback.
I'm going to try and understand what it is telling me about them,
what they need from me,
what they expect of me,
what they expect of someone in this role,
what works for them and what doesn't.
And if I want to work with them effectively,
I may incorporate or adapt with some of that feedback.
So the power of that is that when we're looking at feedback,
as that's information about them,
we don't get defensive.
You never have to decide if it's true or not.
You never have to call your friend and talk about how crazy your manager is or
what they said because it really doesn't matter whether it's true in some
objective sense or not.
What matters is you're getting information about someone who potentially as an
important stakeholder for you.
And when we're not taking it personally,
when we're not making the feedback about us,
something interesting happens.
We start to get really curious about the feedback because it's not personal.
We're not defending against it.
Oh,
interesting.
They,
I hmm.
They think I'm not connecting with people.
I would love to understand more like what is their vision of what that looks
like or,
uh,
how do they see that fitting into my job?
Where would that happen in the flow of my work,
right?
We can ask a lot of questions.
We can learn more.
We can be truly open and then we can adapt and incorporate the feedback.
But from the perspective of that's what it takes to be effective here.
Not from the perspective of there's something defective about me.
Okay.
And that is so important for us,
particularly for women,
for people of color,
because the feedback we get is often going to be impacted by bias.
And we don't want to take that on and make it about us.
We want to allow it to be looked at more neutrally.
And with mark curiosity,
what is this telling me about what it takes to be effective in this context?
So thoughts,
questions on anything we talked about today.
And this is a great time.
I always say this is a great time to not listen to your inner critic,
right?
Take that first step of if you hear the voice in your head saying that question,
does I not?
It's not well thought out enough yet.
Or it might not not be a good question.
Or maybe she said that and I wasn't.
I didn't catch it.
That's your inner critic.
So this is a great opportunity to practice not listening to that voice.
While a woman may receive more negative feedback about their,
um,
about more personal attributes that they may leave a get actually less like,
useful graphical feedback about things they can do to grow,
um,
that,
uh,
men in the same position do.
So,
um,
yeah.
Any,
any thoughts on that and maybe strategies for getting more of that kind of feed?
Yeah.
And I'm not sure if you're referring,
there was one study that came out last fall about the feedback that women get
tends to be more general and more vague.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Um,
just that it's another really important thing to be aware of.
Right?
I think for,
for men and women,
knowing these trends are so important because it means if you look at your
performance review,
you can say,
oh,
this is a lot of this feedback is personality driven.
There's nothing specific here that's tied to the core objectives for my role.
Okay.
That's not just me.
I know that's part of a larger pattern and that's potentially then something you
might want to ask for.
And more specifically,
um,
if you're in the kind of team or department where you can have a constructive
discussion outside of specific performance reviews,
like circulate those articles,
right?
And make sure everybody who's giving and receiving performance reviews is aware
of those patterns so they can catch themselves in them.
Um,
I spoke at a company a few years ago and was talking about this,
the,
the personality feedback thing and uh,
talking about the word abrasive and how abrasive as you know,
it's very commonly used with women.
It's never used with men.
And there was a male
executive in the audience who said,
I just use that word in three performance reviews last week with three women and
now I realize I need to go change it.
So I think raising the awareness there is huge.
And then asking for more specific feedback and feedback around your objectives
for your job is really important if you,
if you see that happening in your reviews.
Um,
one thing that I think a lot of women at Google struggle with,
because tech can be a very,
very male dominated world,
and I personally work in sales at Google.
So business is also fairly male dominated world,
is that there's this constant conflict between discomfort in the situation that
you're in and wanting to improve it and wanting to make sure that people are
educated about implicit bias and all that good stuff,
but at the same time yearning for a community where that doesn't have to be that
it's already understood.
So in your experience coaching,
did you ever find women that were also dealing with that dichotomy and how did
you coach them through it?
Yeah.
Um,
I would just say I think that's a really important need.
I would even,
I would go further than to say it's a want,
it's a need to have that kind of likeminded community or community where you
feel like you're not,
you don't have to be in change agent mode and navigating,
how exactly do I be a diplomatic change agent,
right.
All the time.
Um,
and that can happen in a lot of ways.
It could happen with women inside your organization if there's an opportunity
for that.
Um,
it is the reason that I think a lot of women,
um,
do things that even our cross industry,
whether that's a group coaching experience or uh,
you know,
some other kind of cell form women's group or a book club that talks about these
issues or whatever,
it's just so tremendously nourishing for people.
And I would just really encourage you to create that whatever way you can.
Um,
what was the most challenging pushback you experience in trying to play big and
speak up personally or,
yeah,
uh,
that's a great question.
Well,
I'm writing a lot of political pieces now,
so that's interesting.
I get some pushback,
um,
around that.
Uh,
and you know,
for me it's usually around political or social issues and that's definitely a
playing big edge for me that I still grapple with.
Like,
how much do I really want and how much am I really willing to speak out about
what's Hap,
what I perceive as happening in our collective mill.
You.
Um,
and yeah,
I just find the more radical I get with that,
the more pushback I get.
So it's a good playing big edge for me and I think,
you know,
we should,
we're all always on this journey of what's,
what's my playing big edge now?
What feels really scary but important now?
That doesn't end.
Yeah.
In terms of educating those around us.
So the men in the room,
um,
especially when they're in very senior leadership positions and you can see,
certain characteristics and behaviors kind of trickle through all of the layers.
Um,
how,
I mean,
coming to talks like this is fantastic,
but how do we help bring that message outward?
Yeah.
So the interesting thing is that I've,
I believe the education really needs to happen for everyone and not just women
for themselves,
but women for how they manage and work with other women.
Um,
the research,
you know,
for example,
the research on the double bind that women are often perceived as competent or
likable,
but not both.
That phenomenon is worse with a female manager than a male manager.
And a lot of times there is a kind of policing that women have done of their own
voices or their own expression or whatever.
They had to compartmentalize on the way up that really makes it hard for them to
fully support other women.
So I think,
you know,
it's,
it's really important to think of the education as in the conversation as
needing to happen for everyone.
Um,
and it's tricky because with,
with leaders,
and I would say even particularly with female leaders,
the most important thing is that they're doing their own playing big work
because you,
you really can't support and another,
as a woman,
you cannot,
you will not end up supporting and another woman what you are not allowing
yourself.
So if you're walking on egg shells with the way you express your voice,
you really don't want it direct report who's not,
that's not gonna go over well.
Right?
So,
um,
that,
and I think that's really important for everyone to reflect on how do I do my
own playing big work,
knowing that it's going to change my ability to embrace and support others'
ambitions that's more effective than,
you know,
receiving an education.
Thank you everyone.